Speaker 1: Let's try instead Zach from St.
Louis.
I feel like it's been a while since we've
heard from anybody from from St. Louis.
Zach from St. Louis.
You're on.
What's going on today?
Speaker 6: David, thanks for picking on me.
Appreciate everything you do, by the way.
Thank you.
In regards to covid, this is a conversation
I've been having frequently with family and
friends.
You know, to get back home from Afghanistan
for a minute is how do we come back from this
edge we're on?
You know, there's a there's a set of people
who and I've just kind of looked at the anti
Marzook anti vaccine people
Speaker 4: as two camps, the people who
Speaker 6: are going out of the way to do
everything possible to move the goalposts.
And they are never going to do this.
And then they're skeptics.
And I think with all the the FDA approval
and is on the horizon for that as well, I
think that's going to help a lot of the skeptics.
But the people who are antsy, like they seem
like they'd rather die than get the shot.
They put things they don't even understand
what it is in their body to get this shot.
And I, I, I'm completely just gobsmacked with
my family and friends as to how we unprogramed.
I don't think these people can be deprogrammed.
It's a cult, but I don't think they can be
deprogrammed and I just don't want to bring
it back.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, unfortunately, I agree with you.
I wish it were different, but I did a segment
earlier this week called Sorry guys, the trumpets
are too far gone.
I do believe that there were some people who
in good faith were saying if and when this
gets full approval, I'll go and get the vaccine
to take the approval issue for a second.
I think there were people who in good faith
were saying that and some of them are going
to go now and get vaccinated because it was
fully approved.
There are others who were just always looking
for whatever, just out of reach requirement
they can put in place to avoid getting vaccinated.
I don't think there's any bringing them back.
And unfortunately, it is going to lead to
death.
It's not going to be just their death.
It's going to lead to death among some people
who do get vaccinated.
But they get infected by these people anyway
because the vaccines aren't 100 percent effective.
I want to be convinced by someone in the audience
that there actually is something that can
be done to bring these people back.
I don't really think there is one thing that
comes to mind is we can play really dumb,
childish, reverse psychology with them.
Right.
Like, hypothetically, if it came out that
Biden was going to ban the vaccine, I think
many of them would say, oh, I'm going to go
and get it, screw Biden.
But that's very I mean, you can't really run
a country that way, you know, and it's only
those types of ideas that I think would work
to convince them, sadly.
Speaker 6: Right.
And I think and my biggest fear, and I I'm
not a pessimist, I'm just a realist.
And I think this is going to end in violence,
unfortunately, because I don't think Biden
is ever going to come out and political suicide
himself and, you know, wide mandate, you know,
federal mandate on the vaccine.
I think it was I agree.
We're already seeing like LSU is requiring
CBS Corporation is requiring it, et cetera,
et cetera.
You'll start to see more and more of these
mandates of the business and corporate level
to kind of squeeze people more.
Right.
I'm afraid that once we squeeze, you know,
you back a injured animal into a corner, they're
going to lash out.
And I feel like it's only going to end the
violence because they aren't able to be brought
back from that edge.
Speaker 1: I worry that you're right.
I hope that you're wrong, but I worry that
you're right.
And right now, there's nobody who's talking
me out of this belief.
I increasingly am thinking that your analysis
is spot on.
Let's hope that we're both wrong, you know,
Speaker 6: and don't get in.
Well, yeah, that'll do it for me.
Thank you again for having me on.
Speaker 1: All right.
I appreciate it.
Perfect audio.
Perfect question.
Very much.
Good to hear from you.